ah
let's check up on owen stocker oh yeah
what's she been up to cat i am the
goddess queen beaver
queen bee versus beg bear oh good now
the fake one's gonna start talking in
the chat and be like look at me
i'm here no you're not shut up
peoples around the world
find what you're looking at oh the title
of the video i hope
oh weenie doesn't shoot me please stop
with the go back home it's gone
the daughter is in california that's a
good title for video that is
do you recognize the leaves
i can't get any closer but
the light will come up i don't know if
you can hear the galls and the
geese and stuff when your finger's not
over the mic
yeah we can hear it right next to canada
but this is a bamboo
tree okay this whole thing here
can you recognize these are bamboo
leaves this whole
thing wow wall very interesting
surrounding this house you know the
thing about crazy people is
is that they think that what they're
looking at
is also super interesting to you
but it's not well it's like hanging out
with somebody who's on acid but you're
not on acid
you're like i don't care about the
lights bro yeah it doesn't really matter
bro but bro and you're like i have to
work with them i don't
i'm not i'm not i get it hallucigens are
great
uh but i'm not on them right now please
please be advised of that when you keep
trying to tell me
to look at things and go man don't you
see it no i know
no peace i don't know if you can hear
that or not i end up doing this
community service for everyone whether
you like
deny it or not a lot of people
are supportive the people who are
ignorant
can i ask you a question not to you but
to this woman
or anybody if you're such a if you're a
healer
right and you're this amazing spiritual
and physical healer and everything why
does she always sound so
goddamn miserable and sick sick and
miserable like yeah
i've never heard somebody claim to be
this
like say what you want right there's a
lot of grifters out there that'll be
like i'm a spiritual healer and
namaste and all that [ __ ] but like
they're at least in good shape and they
do yoga and they eat like bean sprouts
and you're like okay you know
at least they're like full of [ __ ] but
they're like with me
you can transform your life and you're
like wow this guy's got at least some
energy and [ __ ] like even the old 80s
and 90s like fitness grifters
were always in good shape like body by
jake at least that guy
ruled and they knew they were lying to
fat americans and being like
yeah just buy this like 150 machine and
that'll give you
all the motivation and i guess to stick
to it and be
healthy they're not going to but at
least you're in good shape when you're
marketing your [ __ ]
this woman's just like you know all my
healing i guess you know you don't want
to be more like
me all healthy
i don't know why people don't want to be
like
me i'm living in my car and i'm healthy
well the jacob scott show's got a really
good point he goes she takes turmeric
bro
she's healthy as a horse she sounds
miserable and as roy said also unhealthy
she sounds so sick
miserable program to the ones making fun
of me so if you see their comment
that's us in under my video take note of
their name they're advertising how
[ __ ] they are how mind control they
are
that's fair attack a 69 year old
but hold on nice
sorry go ahead sorry nice um
how dare you [ __ ] how no
how [ __ ] d first of all stop
everyone stop hiding behind your age or
your
weight or your disability or your
blackness
or whatever the [ __ ] it is stop it
all of you stop it you want to be on
youtube
you're going to that will forever be the
way it is
and susan wojcicki and all her little
meddling with the [ __ ] algorithm
none of that is going to save you if
you're going to put your business out
there
your business is fair game i am tired of
the the credit thurnbergs and the
stop it she's just a child you paraded
her in front of the u.n and told her to
make me eat bugs
i'm gonna make fun of this little artist
dems the brakes
if you're gonna be a nut job living in a
car stalking owen benjamin
i'm gonna make fun of you if you're 69
nice
if you're 23 if you're eight years old
if you're living in a car and you're
stalking on benjamin
i'm going to make fun of you people need
to stop
being absolute [ __ ] shows and then when
you call them on it go
wow really you're going to attack us 69
year old women
there are 69 year old women going to the
gym every day
running businesses 69 it's not
this is in 1873. we're not living in
deadwood
where 69 years old is basically 200
years old you're like
i don't know how he's still alive at
this point stop it
you're not elderly you're not you you
you just started [ __ ] being eligible
for aarp
i don't want to hear it you're not all
[ __ ] you're not off the [ __ ]
uh uh you're not off limits you're
[ __ ] crazy
you post your craziness on the internet
i'm a healer oh
my god look at how healthy i sound
we're gonna make fun of you don't do
that [ __ ] tired of that cowardly [ __ ]
wow really you're gonna attack a black
woman
and it's like yes if that black woman is
acting
i'm going to attack her merch never got
over the giving away the 50
mcdonald's gift card it's still it's
like that
[ __ ] chapter that chapped my ass
on a level that i know it did with you
too
and it has nothing to do with like oh
you must love mcdonald's not
really but like i'm in a way better
position than this woman is in life
and if somebody said hey here's a dollar
gift card to mcdonald's i don't take it
thank you that's like germany meals that
is it mcdonald like i'm gonna
be eating for free for like a week
straight at mcdonald's hey good looking
out homie
and this ungrateful was like i don't eat
that stuff
[ __ ] sick of these people elder
who is trying to
do community service here putting my
life at risk
i don't care i i don't want to be in
this world oh boy
that's another that's another red flag
not great that's a red flag
i would hope if i went to his property
he would shoot me
okay this is now getting there okay but
again
i i mean i know this is obviously we're
gonna add this to all the crazy [ __ ]
she's saying
but um again
why why would i look to you for any sort
of spiritual
or or or physical healing or inspiration
when you're living in a car and going i
hope somebody does murder me
i hate everything it's like you're in on
the one breath you're like i can heal
everybody
i'm a healer i even healed myself and
then in the next breath you're like
everything hurts you're like okay but
which one is it right
because i mean like i'm a 37 year old
alcoholic who eats like [ __ ]
i don't take care of myself at all and
you know what some days i feel sluggish
and i and i know why
that is i know why i'm feeling sluggish
i don't take care of myself
but day to day lady yeah i'm feeling
pretty good about life
and it's prospects like you know on any
given night somebody might talk me into
going out i might go
yeah that sounds fun let's go down to a
curtis excellent park and
you know what i mean let's have a
[ __ ] smoke a blunt we'll go watch a
free concert or something
but you just sound like you're giving up
on life but you also want to be an
inspiration and you want everybody to
look to you like you're
like again if you look at these like
indian yogis at least they always look
at peace
and they always look happy and you're
like i want to be like that guy he looks
very happy and they go
oh just focus on the good [ __ ] whatever
they do it's all the bobs and the jeans
they get
that's what it is hello beautiful baby
place to meditate with me i want to say
cat first off if you're looking to harm
yourself please call the
suicide hotline it's 1-800-273-8255
i just want to put that out there susan
see i did the thing i was supposed to do
now let's continue now or
i hear you i got you here i'm just
thinking i got you here
i'll just say this i'm thinking of
rorschach again
that's all
[Laughter]
and then face the consequences of his
conscience
not even anything about courts or
anything
his gut and his con he talks like that
to keep people away
because he's a scaredy bear what do you
mean key people the way when he's been
he
had first of all owen hasn't changed no
he's
not he's the same say what you want
about him he is consistent and
the [ __ ] he's been babbling was
obviously
powerful and moving enough to make you
move across the country to live in a car
and to be his indentured servant
or whatever or i don't know what you
wanted to do we wanted to remember she
said she wanted to help raise the kids
she wanted to help amy cook and she
would be a great nanny oh okay
he has a wife no like right he wanted to
help amy
he has a stay-at-home wife yeah
who look yeah say whatever you want
about owen right but it does seem like
amy's doing right by the kids oh yeah
she's like a good mom
i wouldn't be like oh [ __ ] amy's
watching the kids oh no
like she seems like a pretty decent mom
and you're like no she clearly needs my
help we need crazy town
to join and [ __ ] mess with the like
these kids already got oh butterfly um
of course
playing on repeating owens farm but it's
like you
you already have owen [ __ ] these kids
up they don't need another crazy healer
woman
this woman thinks she's that um she's
the lady from uh game of thrones that uh
daenerys took hostage oh yeah yeah
mr scaredy bear he ain't big yeah he's
big and fat you ever see
who ever saw him in person you did cause
you're stalking him at the post office
you a lunatic anybody that
you know comes up against me i want you
to have known him
talk to him saw him in person before you
say
he thought you had a gun and i mean
he's not wrong to assume that no like
honestly
you should assume everyone that's come
to see you from across the country
uninvited has a gun
all of them [ __ ] were to me
because otherwise you're just
advertising how dumb down and stupid you
are
yes us living in our homes with central
air conditioning system
and jobs are the stupid ones that you
know nothing
you sit you see a man sitting behind a
a camera but you're the one that
worshipped him enough to follow him
like you can't now go back and call them
[ __ ]
but we look at least with us we've been
making fun of owen since day one
you know all you see is his sloped
shoulders well first of all all right
stop asian american hate just because he
was on sullivan's and sons doesn't mean
yeah you're thinking of steve burnley
that's correct he's thinking of the
other guy
he has sloped shoulders and a sloped
face and a sloped everything really the
whole package
is sloped head to toe
oh [ __ ]
you know the frozen nation goes hey
sorry frozen scene hey
his big fat body
he don't show you around his barn in his
house
because why why would why would he why
would he give up his offset
no for real like i
hey lady do you understand there's a
reason why like if i'm gonna go for a
walk or something and i'm gonna stream
or if i'm gonna stream outside of my
house or my apartment like
i make sure that i'm at work even when i
do a car like i've done
[ __ ] where i put the thing on the mount
in the car and i go for a ride oh yeah
yeah
i make sure i'm like four or five blocks
away in a different neighborhood and
then i hit record
i just you know like that's good opsec
lady like anybody
that's notable on the internet should
probably make sure that people can't
just
like specifically find like a street
sign with both cross streets on it
because then you're [ __ ]
no that's why you had to find him at the
post office and what he's up to
how he's lying to everybody
it was a little bitter i don't think
owen
at least her accusing owen of lying to
everybody
i don't think owen ever said come to my
house and i'll take care of you
like that's the lie that she's saying
that he did but i don't think owen ever
said hey come to my home and live with
me
yeah in my barn owen is an absolute but
he's not that street where i am
and owen knows that you guys are [ __ ]
kooks which is why
he specifically was like uh
by the way nobody gets to live here
you're basically just giving me money
wait where is she oh no
huh dollar tree this is blaine
washington
oh she's back in washington okay the
lights coming up so
you've been in your car in this
residential neighborhood i'm sure they
love you oh yeah you know that she gets
a lot of knocks on the window like ma'am
you're gonna have to move your vehicles
people live here
it's hard for me to hold this thing
still
i guess i could just sit it down
no
way i could just
anyway so i wanted to
this is right next to canada
yes and i accidentally went into canada
and it's set up like so that people
i think end up trapped there and that's
how they
prey on people wait wait canada set up
to trap you so they prey on you
mm-hmm i didn't know that canada's a big
honey pot
that's all it is maple syrup one giant
fed honey pot
people innocent people that
have stuff in their car that they can
nail them on
that's very specific to you lady it
sounds like you're talking about you
what'd they bust away innocent people
that live in their car and have drugs
in their car who are 69 years old
who wanted to go to bataria well i went
through
five hours of their [ __ ]
but it turned out to be a good thing did
it because when i first got there they
were
all over me like i was some kind of
[ __ ] criminal
you're not criminal they were over you
because you're [ __ ] crazy yeah
and luckily i declared yeah ryan goes
the famous canadian grabblers
coming after you mine are caught i had
narcotics in the car i had
cannabis in the car wait a minute what
hold on cannabis whatever we can't
weed's legal in canada so that wouldn't
matter
but you had did she say she had
narcotics in her car
let's go back and see because she might
have been she was just talking about
they were
she might have said something about they
were trying to see if i had all right
let's see i went back up like
10 seconds well i went through five
hours of their
[ __ ] but it turned out to be a good
thing
because when i first got there they were
all over me like i was some kind of
[ __ ] criminal okay
and luckily i declared all mine are
caught i had narcotics in the car i had
cannabis in the car and it was all
legal in washington but as soon as
you're right there at the board it's
legal in canada too
but you're at the border so they can
[ __ ] you over
even though it's legal on both sides of
that imaginary line that they set up
so they can pull their authority trips
on you yeah that's a good point aesop's
right
wheat is legal in canada but you're not
allowed to bring it over the border
it's a weird thing it is true they want
you to buy it there yeah of course
but it's it's it is silly but at the
same time like
i mean this lady's a [ __ ] mess dude
and i love that like
the more she does these videos the more
you learn like
she really is just a bag of [ __ ] person
yeah of course
well i went in under that first shift
which were a bunch of [ __ ] demons
and did you have narcotics or controlled
substances because controlled substances
are
pharmaceuticals prescription drugs and
if you had prescriptions for them then
clearly they wouldn't be able to harass
you
or was it narcotics like was it street
drugs
was it cocaine like i want to know what
she had and
and also how she's also lying like how
do you accidentally go into canada like
every main road that goes to the canada
goes
you're heading towards the canadian
border there's going to be a stop
there's going to be a stop at the
canadian border
these things are not allowed in canada
there will be there will be a whole wall
of signs that will say
last exit before the border yeah
this is it if you're just trying to find
a gas station
this is it for you pal there'll be a
million signs going to mexico or canada
going
last chance to turn around because they
want to be able to bust you if they
participate they want to be able to go
look i mean you had intent to cross the
border you passed
500 signs and a bunch of flashing lights
lesbians and authoritarians and
wait what there was only a couple decent
nice people to me
the one guy that reminded me of joe
patchy
she almost said it right the first time
too but she corrected her stuff to say
it right joe picture
you know he was in the great fellas
that wanted to keep giving me water and
juice
which i refused and you probably looked
dehydrated
crackers she was offering you crackers
and juice yeah he was
if i don't eat that garbage what are you
doing [ __ ] living in your car over
here what are you [ __ ] you want some
[ __ ] crackers or something
what if really joe actually really did
help this woman
but she's so crazy it's like the boy who
cried wolf it's the one true thing and
nobody believes
he just came up to her in new york one
day i was like what are you [ __ ]
doing over here
sitting out here you ain't even got no
[ __ ] crackers or juice here take the
[ __ ] cracker take the [ __ ] juice
he's working on a roll that's why he did
it you know the actors do that he's just
working for a role that he's doing
tell me you gambled the [ __ ] crackers
i'll give you the [ __ ] crackers back
degenerate [ __ ] you you allowed me into
canada
[Laughter]
when the [ __ ] did i ever ask you if i
could come to canada
you better bring the mountain police pal
uh you know what he's like [ __ ] i'm
bringing heat down on you
do you have any phone calls i'm getting
from back home oh and benjamin calling
me saying you're going on youtube
they think you're [ __ ] with batshit
[ __ ]
you could have had your house back in
the other state without going on [ __ ]
youtube
you wanted to go on youtube you could
add the [ __ ] food and beverage job
without going on youtube you made me pop
your [ __ ] eye over poutine
[Laughter]
you've been warned pal don't ever
[ __ ] go to owen benjamin's house
again
[ __ ] hear me yeah but what if i want
to go after it again to get some of that
maple syrup that i like
it would have to be her life yeah oh
what if i just want to go to get one of
those sandwiches i like no you're not
you're banned
you're on the list with you're on the
list with eric nimmer
that's it yeah that black book is
[ __ ] anyway there's only seven names
in it one of them's eric nimmer
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah i tell you what you have three more
days of beating this prick i'll tell you
what coddington you wouldn't [ __ ]
you would have given up me up by now
oh [ __ ] oh you grabbler [ __ ] you
this lady's the best so i wanna know joe
pez she gave her crackers
okay look i'm not gonna top that i'm
gonna stop right there